last time
we discussed standard reduction
potential this e naught prime
value that really is a way to quantitate
the propensity of a molecule
to accept or donate electrons
and this is useful to think about
how energy is transduced in biological
systems because
remember as i have now tried to
stress many times how energy
is moved through biology is largely
about
oxidation and reduction reactions
involving
carbon and ultimately oxygen and so
remember that oxidation of carbon
is favorable that is removing electrons
from the carbon
and giving them to oxygen exactly what
we described for burning wood or burning
gasoline
and so that's why coming from the most
reduced carbon like fatty acids or
other reduced carbon like carbohydrates
not as reduced as fatty acids
that oxidizing that carbon
releases energy and of course it means
that
storing carbon as reduced carbon either
as carbohydrates or fatty acids
is a way to store energy for later
and so moving from left to right
equilibrium strongly favors moving to
the right that means that
delta g is less than zero for the
oxidation of carbon
or we can describe this as moving from a
smaller standard reduction potential to
a larger standard reduction potential
because remember the relationship
between the change in standard reduction
potential
is related to um the equilibrium
constant or delta g
not prime um which is also related to
the equilibrium constant
by the above formula
and so we closed last time
by saying that with this formula we know
that if we move from a smaller standard
reduction potential
that is donate electrons from a smaller
standard reduction potential
to a larger standard reduction potential
that
that number that difference will then be
um positive which is the opposite of
delta g because of that formula and so a
positive change in standard reduction
potential
moving from lower to higher is going to
be
equilibrium is going to favor that
direction
okay should make sense from everything
we
discussed before and of course that
change
tells you the propensity of electron
transfer that
ultimately is going to be favorable at
equilibrium
however exactly as we discussed for
delta g whether an exact reaction is
favorable
is still going to be dependent on delta
g and so
the change in standard reduction
potential tells you about the
equilibrium constant
and so which direction is going to be
net favorable at equilibrium
however what actually happens is still
going to depend on conditions
for all the reasons we talked about
previously
still this change in standard reduction
potential is still
a useful concept to think about
because it tells us about how energy
transfer can occur across
redox pairs and that will be useful
in thinking about this process of
oxidative phosphorylation and how
cells really couple electron transfer
to oxygen as a way to do
lots of useful things in cells including
making atp now one point i want to
come back to again which we discussed at
length when we talked about
uh changes in free energy and how that
worked for
pathways is that you know remember we
discussed that if we start
with wood or oil and all in one step
burn it to co2
it releases a certain amount of energy
or
we can break that into individual steps
as we did
in glycolysis the same amount of energy
is released but by breaking it into
individual steps
we can now capture that energy as
intermediates such that we can
say favorably synthesize atp at a high
atp adp ratio in cells
the exact same thing is true about any
of these electron transfers
there is the change in standard
reduction potential or the change in
free energy as one moves from electron
transfer from
one acceptor to one donor is the same if
you go in one step
or in many different steps and so by
doing these stepwise
electron transfers in exactly the same
way we discussed
about for glycolysis we can capture that
energy release in smaller packets
and this is a way to basically better
harness this energy release
to do useful things for cells ultimately
you'll see it's how you make atp but it
can do other work as well
generate heat move ions etc
and so this is really
what i want to discuss today but it's
important to remember
these concepts um when we think through
how these systems work and so we've now
spent several lectures discussing the
chemical details of how we can oxidize
first we discuss carbohydrates then we
discuss fatty acids
and what we saw is that many of the
electrons that are lost from the carbon
oxidation
are used to generate
molecules such as nadh
or fadh2 and effectively
charge up a ratio if you will
of reduced oxidized cofactors
and these molecules then donate those
electrons
ultimately to oxygen and it's that
how you couple those electron transfers
from these carriers to oxygen
ultimately is what oxidative
phosphorylation is about
as a way to um allow cells to
convert this energy released into a
biologically
useful form now effectively the way
biology does this
is by using that favorable electron
transfer
to oxygen to charge a battery
so really oxidative phosphorylation if
you will
is about a biological battery and it's
really the same concepts that you may
have learned in other courses about how
chemical batteries work
and so let's just think about that what
is a battery well a battery is
two different solutions of ions usually
that is separated into two compartments
it has a unit of
volts that's exactly what the units are
for this change in standard reduction
potential
is volts by
using that voltage to run a current
between the two
compartments you can do work and
if you short circuit a battery of course
you can get some
heat and so how are these really
made well you basically just need
to get that voltage you need to have
some thing that insulates between those
two compartments so you can then
control electron flow from one side of
the circuit to the other
and it's exactly the same issue that
happens
in biology except biology needs some
insulator between two compartments how
do we create different compartments and
cells
well we create them with membranes and
so
an important function of membranes in
cells
other than things like separating
cellular contents from the outside world
or breaking up different organelles is
that
cells actually require a membrane
they're essential for life
because they are what allows
an insulation between two aqueous
compartments in a way
that you can build a biological battery
that is really central to how
life uses energy as a way to do
work and so life creates
a voltage which i'm going to call delta
psi delta ph we'll come back to that in
a little bit
to basically couple
favorable electron transfer
from say an electron carrier like
nadnadh
to oxygen so re-oxidizing
nadh to reduce oxygen
to water that
is uh moving from a lower to a higher
standard reduction potential
that's favorable delta g dot prime is
negative
net transfer is favorable this
can be coupled to
doing some work that otherwise would be
unfavorable in this case
pumping protons from one side of the
membrane to another
by pumping protons to one side of a
membrane
or the other you create a voltage
membrane potential often abbreviated
delta psi
it's also a ph gradient so
delta ph move protons have
lower ph on one side of the membrane
than the other
and it's this charging of a battery at a
membrane
that is what is captured by oxidative
phosphorylation the
what's typically referred to as that
process as a way
to make atp but of course this is a
useful
thing it's a battery and so it can also
do
other work for cells
now i just want to say
and really stress that this is really
critical this process and it's really
central to
how energy works for cells
you will see that effectively this
is the key steps in photosynthesis do
exactly the same thing
it's how mitochondria work it's also how
bacteria work and
really prokaryotes end up doing this
at their plasma membranes whereas
mitochondria
and chloroplasts end up doing this at
intracellular membranes in eukaryotes
but ultimately it's the same idea
of charging this biological battery that
really allows
um cells to convert uh
do energy conversions in a way that's
useful for them
to to uh to do their
you know allow otherwise unfavorable
things to happen
um in cells now
this works largely because you have this
insulating membrane system which is
of course made of lipids lipids are what
separates the two compartments remember
we discussed earlier that
these lipid bilayers are useful because
they create a
hydrophobic interface between two
aqueous
compartments it's also useful because
lipids are
poor conductors of electrons
and so this really ends up being the
insulating system that makes this work
now in the previous lecture we discussed
a lot about the polar and nonpolar
properties of phospholipids really allow
them to assemble
into these membrane barriers and i just
want to do a
slight diversion to revisit this in the
context of
how this works for bioenergetics
so remember you have this lipid bilayer
where you separate
two
aqueous compartments
with this hydrophobic membrane in this
membrane
are these phospholipids
where you have these polar head groups
with
two lipid tails you can look back to a
former
lecture where i drew and we disguised
that you know discuss what those
phospholipids are in great detail
but it's really having that polar
non-polar interface that allows you to
form these bilayers
that's creating this separation between
the aqueous compartments but also
this insulator that allows a battery to
be built
across the membrane
now there are several consequences
though
to this system that is worth thinking
about
at least in terms of how lipids and
membranes
work now a consequence of this is that
if we're going to create this system
now we create a system where we have
issues
with transport
across the from one compartment to
another
now this of course is an opportunity for
a layer of regulation
because it also allows then these
conditions where you can have
different chemical conditions say
different atp adp ratios nad nadh ratios
in the different compartments which of
course for all the thermodynamic reasons
we've already discussed can
make things more or less favorable to
occur in different compartments
in cells but it also means metabolism
then has to have ways to
transport stuff across these membranes
and we've discussed this a couple times
a few examples i talked briefly about
the pyruvate carrier
that is if glycolysis is happening in
this compartment in the cytosol
and we need to get the pyruvate inside
the mitochondria
across a membrane to for the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction now you needed
this pyruvate carrier molecule and it
turns out that that transport process is
an opportunity for regulation
but it still needs to occur we discussed
the carnitine
shuttle right fatty acid
are we generate fatty acyl coas from
breakdown of lipids in one side and the
cytosolic compartment
need to get those fatty acyl coas into
the mitochondria
where they can be oxidized by fatty acid
oxidation and that required that
carnitine shuttle system now ultimately
what mediates this transport is of
course
proteins that can sit within
this membrane bilayer you can imagine
you can have proteins that span the
membrane bilayer such that there's
hydrophilic surfaces that are on either
face of the membrane and hydrophobic
residues in the middle
with various ways to make channels and
other transport mechanisms to get things
from one side of the membrane to the
other
all right or you could have complexes
that float freely
within the lipid bilayer such that
there's a hydrophilic surface
that faces one compartment and a
hydrophobic surface
that faces the inside of the membrane
now having these complexes
will become very important for ways in
which
one can regulate processes that occur
either within the membrane or by moving
things across membranes like
generating moving protons and generating
a voltage
but it has additional consequences
or even move large things like proteins
across the membrane
but it has additional consequences
because it now means that the properties
of the membrane
also matter somewhat as well and this
brings us back to the other discussion
we had in the last lecture
and that is how the various properties
of the fatty acids that exist
within this hydrophobic membrane
area also now can really
matter because they're going to affect
things about
how leaky this is as an insulator
between the two compartments
as well as how fluid the membrane is
such that things like these proteins
can actually move within this
hydrophobic
barrier between the two compartments
in other words the fatty acid
composition
as well as the lipid species
themselves that is which phospholipid
other
polar lipid species other polar
hydrophobic lipid species
analogous to phospholipids that form up
membranes can change
properties such as how leaky the
membrane is
or how fluid the membrane is
you can imagine if you have a really
rigid membrane surface
you're not going to get any flow of
materials it's not going to be very
leaky
which might be great if you want to
build an insulator between the two
compartments
but it's going to be very difficult to
regulate transport
across that compartment and so nature
has come up with a bunch of different
solutions for how to play with fatty
acid
and other lipid composition to change
the properties of membranes
we don't have time to get into that in
great detail in this course but i want
you to appreciate that these things
exist but one thing i want to discuss is
that often when you see
phospholipids drawn like this they're
drawn in this way where the polar head
group is a circle
and then they'll draw the two lipid
tails
often with a kink in one of the lipid
tails that's because many times
phospholipids
of the two lipid tails one is saturated
and one is has a mono unsaturation
in it and i just want to go back to the
models here remember
the mono unsaturated the double bond
ends up being this
cis double bond and so here's two
fatty acids if you put these here in
with the head groups on one side so this
would be esterified to the glycerol the
phospholipid
you end up getting this kink in the
membrane which is much different than
two
straight chains you can imagine that
within the membrane itself
this ends up basically not letting
those lipid tails pack quite so tightly
in the membrane
which certainly contributes to um
an ability to have space to put other
stuff in the membrane
to allow other processes to happen
now recall that there's other ways we
can
modulate the properties of
fatty acids introduce more double bonds
chain length etc and
different organisms use different
strategies
to deal with this and so plants
remember have all kinds of
polyunsaturated fatty acids just like we
talked about with
plant oils being liquid at room
temperature having more
polyunsaturated fatty acids in their
lipid tails is one way plants use
to keep their membranes more fluid
animals remember have more saturated
fatty acids
all right those saturated fatty acids
higher
less double bonds going to be higher
melting temperature more likely to be
solid at room temperature
so that's not going to be very good for
membrane fluidity and it turns out
animals use a different strategy to keep
membrane fluidity that's not
polyunsaturated fatty acids and that is
that they incorporate
this molecule shown here on the slide
which is
cholesterol which you're well aware of
and so animals use
use sterols like cholesterol as a way to
keep their membranes more fluid and so
that cholesterol
that is present in animal products
is not there to give you heart attacks
it's really there
as a way animals use to keep their
membranes fluid
and this is really at heart why plants
are cholesterol free foods
and animals have cholesterol and it's
because
animals use cholesterol as a way to keep
their membranes fluid
whereas plants use a different strategy
polyunsaturated
fatty acids all right
now ultimately setting up the system
this way
is important because it allows for these
flexible membranes that can
enable ion and other transport between
compartments
as well as hold the charge so that you
can form
this battery which allows
oxidative phosphorylation or other
processes
to occur where you can charge this
membrane and
ultimately use that voltage
to do work like make atp
all right now
how this membrane charging occurs
again is really taking advantage of
favorable electron
transfer across a series of
redox pairs ultimately to
oxygen or another good electron acceptor
and it's really that
favorable electron transfer that's being
coupled
to this pumping of proton ions to
charge a battery that's the oxidation
part
and then that battery doing work
such as driving favorable adp to atp
conversion the phosphorylation part of
oxidative phosphorylation
is the type of work that you can then do
once you generate this chemical battery
although not the only work
you can do with that battery and it's
why this is so much more flexible
than just making atp
all right so ultimately
this process by coupling
transfer of electrons from favorable
oxidation of carbon
to charge up these other electron
carriers
that ultimately transfer to oxygen is
a major way that life
uses nutrient oxidation to
convert it to biologically useful energy
and this is where we get to this process
of what is typically referred to as
oxidative phosphorylation
which is a concept or a process that was
often abbreviated oxfos
and it was discovered by or first
described by a gentleman by the name of
peter mitchell
and like many novel or revolutionary
ideas
when peter mitchell first described or
proposed
the processes are about to tell you
about his ideas were initially
dismissed okay it was thought at the
time
when people were thinking about how do
you couple metabolism to
say charge up your atp adp ratio that
that process would work via the
oxidative phosphorylation
type reactions that we otherwise
described things like what happens at
the gap dh step
or the succinct thiokinase step in the
tca cycle
those are two examples where we could
directly couple
the oxidation of carbon
to a phosphorylation event that
ultimately allowed us
to favorably produce atp
to maintain an atp adp ratio that's high
and is present in cells however
what peter mitchell described was really
this
battery phenomena that we're talking
about
and it turned out to be largely right
and
represents something that's actually
quite unique
about biological processes even if you
think about other biological processes
that occur
and that is what he proposed was
is that the oxidation
and phosphorylation
events were actually separate
processes
that is nature does not have to have
these two things
touch in order for them to work that is
that you
use oxidation to create this battery
as one event and then that battery
so oxidation
generates
this potential across a membrane and
then that
potential across a membrane as a totally
separate event
can drive
phosphorylation
okay adp
or do other work ultimately making this
a more
flexible system for biology
and so turns out as i said before
in a prokaryotic cell so this here is a
some kind of prokaryote okay
prokaryotes have a membrane that
separates them from the outside world
this cell membrane
effectively couples that oxidation
step to the pumping of protons that
creates
a
battery at the cell membrane of the
prokaryote
and separate in space
that can then be used to drive
atp synthesis or do other work
that's useful to maintain that
prokaryotic cell now in
eukaryotes
this process occurs at membranes within
the mitochondria so if this here is a
mitochondria okay so just to remind
you of some very basic
cell biology and so remember
mitochondria have
two membranes so there's this outer
mitochondrial membrane
outer mitochondrial membrane and then
there's this
inner inner mitochondrial membrane
okay so two membranes in the
mitochondria
remember there's this matrix
space the cytosol
would be out here and then there's this
space between
the two membranes called the
inter membrane
space inner
mem inter membrane space between the two
membranes
if you'll recall many of these oxidation
reactions the tca cycle
fatty acid oxidation pyruvate
dehydrogenase
step all of those were happening in the
matrix
of the mitochondria remember glycolysis
was in the cytosol
but all these other processes were
happening in the matrix of the
mitochondria
and really what's going on is that this
battery
is being charged across this inner
mitochondrial membrane
okay so protons are being pumped
into the inner mitochondrial membrane
into the inter membrane space of the
mitochondria
and then used to synthesize
atp in the matrix of the mitochondria
now part of this came many people know
remember mitochondria have their own
dna etc and so really
where people thought eukaryotic
eukaryotic cells came from
is basically the mitochondria is an
enslaved
bacteria or a obligate captured symbiont
if you will
where one cell engulfed a different
prokaryotic cell
and if you track this
think of the inner mitochondrial
membrane as
a enslaved prokaryotic cell you can see
that you're generating
this membrane potential
across the inner mitochondrial membrane
which is really equivalent
to the bacterial membrane of the
enslaved
prokaryotic cell in both cases
it's creating this battery at a membrane
the inner mitochondrial membrane
or the bacterial membrane of a
prokaryote that is then being used
to separately in space use that gradient
to do work
such as synthesize atp
so if i draw this
more explicitly is this here being
the membrane so the inner mitochondrial
membrane
of a mitochondria or
the bacterial
membrane of a prokaryotic cell such that
this is outside the bacteria
that's inside the bacteria this is the
inner membrane space often referred to
as the
cytosol side of course there's another
outer mitochondrial membrane here that
for the
sake of this class you can just think of
as being generally permeable
this would be the matrix side of the
inner mitochondrial membrane
and so all this
nadh is being generated
from nutrient oxidation tca cycle fatty
acid oxidation pyruvate dehydrogenase
whatever
within the matrix or within the bacteria
those electrons are ultimately being
transferred
from nadh re-oxidizing it to nad
to reduce oxygen to water
this is favorable this is
therefore coupled to pumping protons
that creates
a membrane potential and ph gradient
across this membrane which
can be used to do
[Music]
work such as
driving the synthesis of
atp or other work so
this all has to happen at the same
membrane
but this process does not have to touch
that process it's coupled because you
create this battery
this membrane potential and ph gradient
that can be done that can be used
elsewhere along the membrane to do some
kind of
work now i draw this as delta psi delta
ph you can imagine if you're moving
protons you're going to create a voltage
you're also going to create a ph
gradient it turns out i don't have time
to discuss this further in the class a
lot is written about
how to think about this membrane
potential as either
a true voltage or as a ph gradient
it turns out that they're useful to
think about in different ways for
different processes
but if you're interested in this there's
certainly lots written about this on
various um
you know papers and texts on on on
bioenergetics and i would encourage you
to
to read more about that okay
all right what i want to do next then is
discuss each of these processes in turn
that is how does this work
and how does that work um
to really understand what's going on
um in mitochondria and bacteria to
to to carry out this process of
oxidative phosphorylation
so first let's talk here first how does
one
use favorable
electron transfer to make
this membrane potential
obviously if we're going to pump protons
against a gradient such that we have
different proton gradient
on different concentration of protons on
either side of the membrane
that's going to require energy input and
that energy
is going to come from favorable electron
transfer
and so really this process
[Music]
is
taking electrons from say a cofactor
like
nadh and
ultimately
transferring those electrons to oxygen
to get
water the standard reduction potential
of nadnadh is less
than the standard reduction potential of
oxygen in water
that means that equilibrium is going to
favor
electron transport in this direction to
say it another way
and relative to oxygen water nadnadh is
a better electron donor
oxygen water is a better electron
acceptor
pair and so by
this electron transfer being favorable
it
can be used then to release energy
coupled to other processes such as
moving protons
and make that otherwise unfavorable
process
favorable now you'll note
that in doing this we now regenerate
the oxidized cofactor nad plus and so
that solves our electron balance problem
for glycolysis
solves any electron balance problem that
would exist for
fatty acid oxidation or the tca cycle
in the mitochondria because ultimately
those electrons are being given
to oxygen and so oxygen being this final
electron acceptor being
stoichiometrically
produced to generate water is
effectively water being the alternative
waste product
to say lactate or ethanol that we saw in
fermentation all right now as
we started the lecture with and
discussed in glycolysis
if we do this in one step it's favorable
but it's also favorable
if we do it in lots of little steps
by doing it in lots of little steps just
like we did in glycolysis
we can break up that energy release in a
way to allow us to do
more work right so on glycolysis
we could turn carbohydrate
into co2 one step burning wood release a
lot of light and heat
all in one step that can be used to do
work
but it was more efficient to break it up
into little steps where we could then
capture intermediates that made atp
synthesis favorable
despite a high atp adp ratio same idea
here we could transfer this all in one
step
but instead you break it up into a bunch
of individual steps
which can then be coupled individually
to pumping protons across the membrane
to generate more efficiently this uh
delta psi delta ph charge this battery
and so this occurs across
a series of electron carriers
multi-protein
complexes electron carriers called the
electron
transport chain
okay and you can think of this electron
transport chain
as being entirely analogous to what we
already talked about
when we talked about how pyruvate
dehydrogenase or alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase works when we talked about
the tca cycle
remember these have these different
protein complexes this e1 e2 e3
where electrons were transferred across
this chain it's exactly the same idea
here
a number of multi-polypeptide encoded
protein complexes that come together
to hold a bunch of electron carriers
that break up the energy release if you
will
as we oxidize nadh and reduce
oxygen and transfer those electrons
along the chain
with the complexes themselves coupling
the favorable electron transfer
to the moving of protons against a
gradient
across the membrane to work and so
for this electron transport chain to
work
we obviously need a bunch of electron
carriers
and why you need more than one electron
carrier should now be obvious
because having different carriers at
that sit at
different standard reduction potentials
is going to be
useful if we want to build a change such
that we can have
favorable oxidation and reduction
to move electrons in a favorable
direction and
couple that to processes that allow us
to
charge this battery and so it turns out
that for this electron transport chain
to work
what we know about some of our electron
carriers so we've discussed
nad nadh there's fad
fadh2 there is lipoic acid
lipoic acid is not part of the electron
transport chain
nadnadh is a donor you'll see fad is
can be part of the electron transport
chain but there's a different
there's additional electron carriers i
want to discuss those
now so another important one is
something called
fmn or flavin
mono nucleotide
what fmn or flavin mononucleotide is
it's it's effectively fad
but it's fad not in a dinucleotide state
but
a mononucleotide state so if you take
fad
and you remove an amp group from it what
you're left with is
fmn so just to remind you
to be explicit about this so
a
three four
okay so you have this flavin group
attached to this
ribotol group with a phosphate on it
if i put another phosphate and an
adenine nucleotide here an amp
group attached here that would be fad
this would be
fmn mononucleotide instead of a
dinucleotide
this is fmn in the
oxidized form and just like
fad it can accept
an electron pair so here's our hydride
ion
two electrons we just draw here the
middle part
of the molecule
and so this here would be fm
fmnh2
or
the reduced form of this electron
carrier okay so flavin mononucleotide
part of the electron transport chain now
note fmn
fad nad all of these things are
two electron carriers right we disguised
the mechanism of
all of them just reminded you of it
these hydride ion transfers
two electron carriers turns out the
electron transport chain
also uses metal ions as electron
carriers
and so lots of minerals in our diet
things like iron
it turns out elemental iron is a great
electron carrier and it's very important
for
this for electron transport chain now
elemental metals are one electron
carriers
and so there's a few ways you
incorporate iron
one is something called iron sulfur
clusters
and so iron sulfur clusters is within a
protein
you have some cysteine residues
and those cysteine residues can
coordinate
on iron atom and so that iron
atom can sit in the three plus
versus two plus state okay
oxidized reduced
so reduction of the iron oxidation
of the iron okay so one electron
carrier move one electron that way also
iron sits within molecules called
cytochromes so
what are cytochromes this is a iron atom
that's
basically chelated into a porphyrin
very similar to what you saw for
hemoglobin and so
you have an iron two plus or three plus
that's chelated here into the
this porphyrin ring structure
okay lots of conjugated double bond
systems in it
this should look very similar porphyrin
is the thing on the outside coordinates
an iron atom in the middle
that can move between the two plus and
the three plus state just like we do for
iron sulfur clusters
so carry electrons be oxidized or
reduced
three plus or two plus and ultimately
this porphyrin is
can have some r groups added here
can be associated with it or bound to
cysteine residues within
proteins effectively these molecules
varying these r groups and how it's
attached to proteins
gives you different families of
cytochromes
referred to as cytochrome
a the b type cytochromes and
cytochrome c these are associated with
enzyme complexes cytochrome c it's
actually covalently bound
to the polypeptide itself
basically these are named because you
have these different conjugated
ring structures here that and how the r
groups are will slightly
change so this will absorb visible light
that'll slightly change the absorption
spectra
and so classically based on absorption
spectra these were classified into a b
and c type cytochromes and you can
imagine by
these properties having slightly
different um
you know affecting the iron in ways that
it slightly affects its electron
transport
properties of course hemoglobin
almost certainly evolved from these
molecules as oxygen carrying ways
in multicellular life but of course the
original use was as electron carriers
for the processes here that we're going
to talk about to hold that iron as a way
to
control electron transport across these
electron transport chains
all right so that's iron turns out
iron's not the only metal
that can be used to do this and so cells
also use
copper and so
histidine can coordinate a copper
that can move between an oxidized and
reduced state so copper two plus
reduced to copper plus copper plus to
copper two plus
or copper plus oxidized copper two plus
another
one electron carrier and so iron and
copper
can act as one electron carriers and so
you have these two electron carriers
here's a bunch of metals there's one
electron carriers
obviously you need ways to carry
both one and two electrons if you're
going to move electrons between these
different
carriers and an important molecule to do
that is something called
coenzyme
q all right coenzyme q sometimes
referred to
as ubiquinone
ubiquinol because it's ubiquitous
um often abbreviated
coq many of you have probably heard of
the supplement coq10
okay very popular supplement out there
coq10
is basically a version of coenzyme q
ubiquinone ubiquinol
what this looks like is as follows
so this here is ubiquinone
the oxidized form okay
so this middle part is the quinone
and then you have these decorations on
the outside including this r
group this r group is typically a long
acyl chain if it's 10 carbons long
that's coq10 the supplement
having this long acyl chain makes this a
very hydrophobic molecule
and it actually lives within the
membrane itself
as an electron carrier and so this
ubiquin known can
pick up an electron
as well as a proton
and so by picking up
one electron it can then
basically
go here to this semi quinone
stabilized free radical state and then
pick up
a second electron to go
to the fully reduced form
ubiquinol
okay so one electron carrier and two
electron carrier
so basically can carry two electrons
from the oxidized the reduced form but
can transfer them as single electrons
by going from through this stabilized
free radical
ubiquinone state and so basically
these various electron carriers are
associated with
these protein complexes within this
electron transport chain that ultimately
works to couple
favorable electron transport down the
chain
to pumping protons to generate this
potential
across the membrane all right
so this process
occurs
this process occurs um again
at the bacterial membrane or the inner
mitochondrial membrane
and in animals
and most organisms
operates with four
large multi-subunit protein
complexes all right each of these
protein complexes is
mostly has multiple polypeptides as i
said coming together to form these
complexes just like we described for
pdh for instance most of the
components of this are encoded in the
nuclear genome
but a subset of these are encoded in the
mitochondrial genome
now what exactly is encoded in different
mitochondrial genomes varies
by organisms but across organisms is
basically
mostly complex components of these
protein complexes and so this is why
mitochondrial dna is retained it's kind
of this vestige
of this symbiotic relationship the
mitochondria have retained
some of the ability to control their own
energy
transduction sort of core components of
these complexes
there is one soluble
protein so these complexes are embedded
within the membrane
there's also one soluble protein that's
associated with the membrane
and then there's coenzyme q
which also floats within the membrane
so in the membrane
these are embedded in the membrane
and then there's a soluble protein
that's associated with the membrane
so
okay now i want to discuss the details
of what these protein complexes
are and also
a few comments about how they work
so this is the inner membrane space and
this is the matrix side
be out or in
if we're discussing a prokaryote okay
the first is
we have
something called complex one
complex one also referred to
as nadh
oxidase okay
because it oxidizes nadh
back to nad
nadh oxidase is a
giant complex greater than 900
kilodaltons in total has more than
25
individual protein subunits
contains some flavin mononucleotides
as well as some iron sulfur clusters
as electron carriers and
it is the least well understood
of all of the protein complexes in fact
it is still a major
um field of study to try to understand
how
nadh oxidase really works but it
effectively
is one of the complexes that can pump
protons
across the membrane as those two
electrons are transferred
through the complex from nadh ultimately
to coenzyme
q that exists within
the membrane okay
the next complex is
discuss is complex ii complex
ii is succinate dehydrogenase
the exact enzyme that we heard about
from
the tca cycle so what does succinate
dehydrogenase do
remember it converts fumarate to
succinate
it gave those electrons to fad
to make fadh2
well that occurs within this complex
which can also re-oxidize the fadh2
with those two electrons and give them
also
two coenzyme q that
sits within the membrane so
i want to point out that this
ultimately you will see is why it is
that electron transfer
from nadh and fadh2 has different
energy yields and so the electron
transfer from nadh to
ubiquinone is more of a change in
standard reduction potential
than from fadh2 to ubiquinone
why use fadh2 well because remember
when we did electron transfers we used
when we oxidized a
carbon okay say
in a carbohydrate to a ketone
all right we tended to use nad
plus nadh as the
electron transport pair so this change
in standard reduction potential
is such that we can make that reaction
work
and ultimately drive that it turns out
that
oxidizing a putting a double bond in
okay this going from uh
not oxidizing an alcohol to a ketone but
oxidizing the carbon to a double bond
that this is basically
you need a different change
in standard reduction potential to carry
out
that reaction and make it worse work
fadh fadh2 sits at a
higher standard reduction potential than
nad nadh
and so that means to further transfer
them to
something further downstream
like coenzyme q there's a bigger change
in standard reduction potential here
that can be used to drive protons
there's not enough of a change here
can't use that to drive protons
and it's because of these differences
and what's actually being oxidized
that ultimately leads to this
difference in energetics when we think
about
fadh2 versus nadh and how much
atp equivalents that they might have for
cells
all right once electrons are in the
ubiquinone pool they can now be
or coenzyme q pool they can now be
transferred to complex
three so oh complex
three is
also referred to as
cytochrome c
reductase you'll see why in a second
it's a 250 kilodalton
complex there are 10 subunits
it has a bunch of b type
and c type
cytochromes
as well as some iron sulfur clusters
shown here on the slide from textbook is
a picture
of complex three and
what it actually looks like
fairly well understood how it works
this coupling of basically electron
transfer through the q pool
can pump protons um
and this ultimately allows
transfer of electrons to this
small soluble protein that lives in the
inter-membrane space
or associated with the outside of the
bacteria called
cytochrome c or outside in the inner
membrane space called cytochrome c
cytochrome c
is a 13 kilodalton
protein it's a very small
highly conserved protein with a c-type
cytochrome
commonly used because it's found across
many many different types of organisms
and so it's been
sequenced from many many organisms as a
way to identify evolutionary
relationships
and then cytochrome c this is also why
it's called cytochrome c reductase
because it's reducing cytochrome c
to transfer electrons along the chain
ultimately
to the final complex cyto complex four
complex four also referred to as
cytochrome c oxidase
and this is ultimately
the place where electrons are
transferred
to reduce oxygen to water
so this is a 160 kilodalton
protein complex with 13
subunits uses
a type cytochromes
and copper
as electron carriers
and ultimately allows you to get
electrons from cytochrome c
to oxygen and so here again from the
textbook is a picture of
complex four
and what it looks like also fairly well
understood
also couples electron transport to
proton pumping and so
this is effectively the electron
transport chain as it exists in
mitochondria
and you can draw it a different way
as i will do here so here's
complex one
allows oxidation of nadh
back to nad plus
that oxidation can be coupled
to reduction of fmn
ultimately those are passed
through some iron sulfur clusters
leading to
the reduction of ubric quinone
and in the process this can
electron transport can pump on the order
of four
protons or at least that's what's
estimated
complex ii which is
succinate dehydrogenase from the tca
cycle
really converts succinate
to fumarate that
oxidation reaction
within the complex leads to
[Music]
the reduction of fad to fadh2
that can be re-oxidized
through iron ultimately
driving the reduction
of coenzyme q from ubiquinone to
ubiquinol
that ubiquinone to ubiquinol
in something called the q pool
within the membrane can then
be re-oxidized
in complex
3. that re-oxidized and complex 3
puts electrons
through complex 3 that can be coupled to
pumping on the order of
two protons those electrons
are transferred to cytochrome c
ultimately those electrons are
transferred to
copper in
complex 4 to cytochrome a
and ultimately
oxygen to water
reducing oxygen to water and pumping on
the order of
four protons and so
you can see here that
basically this is a series of
oxidation and reduction reactions that
happens across these complexes
such that complex 1 the
transfer electrons from the q pool
through complex 3 and complex 4
can pump protons across the membrane
and generate this delta side delta ph
that can be used to do work and it's
really the favorable transfer of
electrons either from nad nadh or the
oxidation of the
succinate to fumarate with those
electrons being given to oxygen
to drive this process
and so really just to schematize
this in a way
is that if this is our membrane
nad plus the nadh gives electrons to
complex one
which goes to coenzyme q which goes to
complex three
which grows to cytochrome c which goes
to complex four
and reduces oxygen
to water that is one way to carry out
this set of reactions the other way is
we can
convert fumarate
sorry succinate to fumarate
okay that's the fad that's complex two
also gives it to the q pool and so you
can see that the
electron transport chain would be
complex one q three c
four or two q three c four
it is not one two three four it is
actually
1 to q or 2 to q ultimately going
to 3. now
the way protons are pumped is a process
that i don't have time
this year to discuss in class i will
post something on stellar that is just a
short section from the textbook
that describes at least what is known
about how that process
works such as the q cycle
basically how oxidation and reduction of
coenzyme q which will take protons on
and off the molecule on either side of
the membrane
can be used to show how this can be
coupled to
proton pumping across the the membrane
and you can read that
if you're interested
okay now couple other points
about this this
works because you're moving from a lower
to a standard a higher lower to a higher
standard reduction potential across
the chain and it turns out oxygen
is a particularly good electron acceptor
and this is really why oxygen and
respiration is really so
vital to a lot of the way energy
transduction works in metabolism
oxygen is now abundant and being a great
electron acceptor is why it's used but
of course oxygen was not
abundant two and a half billion years
ago
and it doesn't have to be oxygen for
this to work
if you have another electron acceptor
that
basically makes this process favorable
that can work just as well and in fact
that happens still
in some very extreme environments okay
this so-called chemosynthesis
basically can use other electron
acceptors
to drive the energetics of cells
and you really just need the right
ways to build an electron transport
chain to make this whole system work so
that you can build a battery
and use it to do work okay so oxygen
commonly used because it's abundant and
good
at it but it's not the only way that
this can work and there are examples in
biology where
oxygen is not used that there's other
acceptors that are used
instead i also want to note
as i've alluded to in discussing complex
2
this fad fadh2 so when we talk about
that
in the tca cycle or in fatty acid
oxidation
we discuss it as if it's kind of like
nadnadh
but it's not nad nadh are
basically cofactors that move around
between enzymes
fad fadh2 are not free
these are really part of their electron
carriers
that are part of protein complexes like
what we described up here
okay and they're part of enzymes like
succinate dehydrogenase so complex
ii is just happens to be an
fad fadh2 containing enzyme that's part
of the tca cycle
and part of the electron transport chain
as a way to transfer electrons in the
tca cycle into the
q pool via this succinate to fumarate
conversion acyl coa dehydrogenase the
fad fadh2 enzyme we discussed in fatty
acid oxidation
could easily be drawn instead in an
electron transport chain that goes acyl
coa dehydrogenase
complex coenzyme q3 c4 just like we can
say succinate to fumarate is the same as
complex 2
q3 c4 okay and so
there's really lots of alternative
electron transport chains
that involve these fad fadh2 containing
enzymes
that really sit in the membrane and
directly transfer
electrons to the q pool
ultimately the goal of all of this is of
course to create this
delta psi delta ph which can be used to
charge this battery
that thing can then be done to do work
and so
this work includes the phosphorylation
of atp
and so if we charge this battery
we can now use
this as a way to couple
current in this battery to phosphorylate
adp
to make atp the phosphorylation part
of oxidative phosphorylation
now this occurs also by a large protein
complex sometimes referred to as
complex 5 but remember complex 5 or this
atp synthesis machinery is not really
part of the electron transport chain it
is separate in space
and is basically something a way to
utilize
this delta psi delta ph across the
membrane
to drive atp synthesis
all right how does
this complex 5 or atp synthesis
work
so this is also
a large protein complex sits within
the same membrane of course because it
has to utilize the
membrane potential to function
and this so-called
complex 5 is also referred to
as the atp synthase
or the f0 f1
atp ace and basically
if this is the inner membrane space
this is the inner mitochondrial membrane
this is the matrix you have
a protein complex that sits within the
membrane
called f zero it's actually f
o the o stands for oligomycin
because there's a drug called oligomycin
that inhibits the
f o or f zero part of the
molecule and then there's this f1
component that is associated with the
f-zero component
that sits on the matrix side of the
membrane and it is effectively
the machine that
phosphorylates
or interconverts atp and
adp on the matrix side of the membrane
now it's pretty well understood how this
system works
and basically f1 works by a process
called
rotational catalysis how this works was
awarded the nobel prize in 1997
figured out not all that long ago
and basically this is f1 is a large
protein
complex where you have a gamma subunit
that is attached to f0 that couples
basically proton pumping
to this gamma subunit to literally turn
the f1 component
and change the confirmation of attached
regions parts of this f1
machine because it turns out you can
have three different confirmations
of the rest of f1 the so-called l
or loose confirmation the t or tight
confirmation
or the o or open confirmation
and so in the open conformation
adp and phosphate
or atp
can exchange in and out of
this complex all right
in the loose conformation you basically
have adp and phosphate bound
and in the tight conformation
this is favored
to synthesize atp
and so you can envision that what
actually happens here is that you first
have
adp and atp bind
in this open conformation
okay protons are moved
you get rotation around the gamma
subunit
that changes the conformation of the o
subunit to the loose subunit so now you
have adp
plus pi bound another proton moves
changes the confirmation of the loose
subunit
into the tight conformation
now atp synthesis is
favored another proton moves
comes back to the open conformation
and atp is released from the molecule
and you can run another rotational
catalysis cycle
again to ultimately drive adp to atp
synthesis
using this transfer of protons
across the f0 subunit to ultimately
rotate this machine to synthesize
atp now the way f0 works
is within the membrane and this is
always
hard to draw you basically have
a central piece
with another uh central complex with
another set of complexes around it
that within that have two half channels
that are open to either side of the
membrane
and so if you look at this from the top
view
so looking at it straight down you'd
have this central piece
with this external piece with the two
half channels
that basically can rotate around
the central stalk this is hooked up to
the gamma subunit of f1 in which drives
rotational catalysis
and how this works is that attached to
this
inner piece that is open to the half
channels is an aspartate
residue okay so this is an aspartic acid
residue that's there and
recall that aspartic acid
is an acid so it can pick up a proton
or release a proton from its acid group
depending on
the ph on either side of the membrane
and so remember there's a different ph
on the two
sides of the membrane okay
and it's really that difference in
ph that will allow
favorable turning around this center
stalk
and so the ph in the inner membrane
space is
lower okay so that means you're more
likely to favor
protonation of the aspartate it can then
rotate such that the channel that
aspartate is now exposed to the other
channel to the matrix side
there the ph is higher so favors
deprotonation
and basically this will drive
motion of this piece around the central
stock
that being coupled to the gamma subunit
of f1
will cause rotation of the
f1 subunit changing the attached
conformation of the rest of the complex
to favor atp synthesis and it's really
this
is how you have moving of protons back
from the inner membrane space to the
matrix can drive
the synthesis of atp the phosphorylation
part
of this process
and so now you have a full picture of
how
carbon oxidation really releases energy
in a way that's coupled to do work in
biology
so we can of course couple this directly
as we did
at gap dh or succinct thiokinase but
mostly it's captured to charge up
these nad nadh ratios
where favorable electron transport can
be used to make this delta psi delta ph
in a membrane
that can be used also to synthesize atp
despite a high atp adp ratio
because electron trans because that
battery
can be used to drive this machine
now i want to point out that the atp
synthase is just like any other enzyme
in any pathway
and that is if conditions are right
there's no reason
that this machine has to drive atp
synthesis
it could also consume atp
as a way to create a proton gradient
that is use atp hydrolysis
to pump protons in the opposite
direction into the inner membrane space
well why would you ever do that well you
would do that because having this
battery
is useful because atp is not the only
way that cells can use energy to do work
it turns out that having a membrane
potential is useful for other things so
if you're in course nine you know
that action potentials are carried
basically electricity along
cells what is that that is basically
changing membrane potentials across
cells more generally membrane potentials
can be used to do lots of other
types of work and so atp is only one way
that cells can use
biological energy because it can be
coupled to otherwise unfavorable
reactions
but you can also couple ion gradients to
unfavorable reactions and use that
to do work and so lots of useful ways
that delta psi delta ph
can be used by cells
and so what are some of these well the
first one
is this can be used to generate heat
so if you're checking your phone right
now your phone is obviously a very
useful device to do all kinds of
work for you you can read whatever you
want on your phone
use it to call people but what happens
if you short circuit the battery in your
phone
well it'll get really hot and the same
thing happens here
if i rather than use this delta psi
delta ph to generate atp
if i just put a hole in the membrane
something referred to as an uncoupling
protein on
ucp or uncoupling protein this will just
allow
the leak of protons back across the
membrane
well that's short-circuiting the battery
energy has to be dissipated somewhere
and it's dissipated
as heat and this is effectively
ways in which biology can create heat
and so uncoupling proteins are expressed
in a tissue called brown fat
in mammals brown fat is a way to
generate heat and it's one way that we
maintain our body temperatures
now the system is imperfect and lots of
cells
all metabolism generates some heat if
you've ever done composting you know
your compost pile gets hot
that's because the organisms there that
are metabolizing the material in the
compost pile
are generating some heat and that's
because membranes aren't perfect they're
somewhat leaky
now as humans we work hard to maintain a
constant body temperature
and there's actually a huge amount of
energy that goes into just maintaining
our body temperature but you can imagine
how efficiently
we couple these processes we'll
determine how many calories we need
to maintain heat and that's actually a
theory of weight control
that those of us out there who have less
well-coupled mitochondria can eat more
because they waste more energy in
generating heat than those of us who are
really efficient
in doing this and in fact there's drugs
that allow you to uncouple
electron transport generation of delta
psi delta ph
from utilizing that membrane potential
and these are great weight loss drugs
dinitrophenol
was used middle part of the last century
as a weight loss agent was very
effective the problem is it's also
incredibly dangerous because people will
die because it turns out
if you uncouple this process and you
don't have enough atp you die really
fast
and so don't use that drug but it
illustrates
how you can use this battery to generate
heat another form of
energy another big one is
membrane transport
so if i want to concentrate something
and this could be
moving proteins or it could be
moving other ions like in an action
potential
all right those are unfavorable
processes right i'm
causing dissociation of ions across
membranes okay
or moving protein from one side of a
membrane to another
one can couple those transport processes
to these
delta side delta ph as well and in fact
protein imported in the mitochondria
depends very much on a membrane
potential to get those proteins in
the mitochondria is an important site of
calcium storage for cells
calcium is concentrated in the
mitochondria and that concentration
can be driven by this membrane potential
and of course this potential can also
use
to power lots of shuttles like the
carnitine shuttle
and actually create situations where you
have different conditions across
membranes
as a way to favor different chemistries
and so the last thing i want to mention
is in fact these shuttles
which is just ways that one can couple
membrane potential to drive other things
can also be really important for how
metabolism works
and i just want to illustrate one aspect
of this so if i draw here
my mitochondr
if i draw a mitochondria
so here's all these processes are
happening
here where we have electron transport
generating a potential across the inner
mitochondrial membrane
that can be used to synthesize
atp well this synthesis is occurring
in the mitochondria but ultimately
i need to get that atp out into the
cytosol
for it to be useful for the cell
to run otherwise unfavorable processes
in the cytosol
and so one needs a transporter for this
some transporter called the adenine
nucleotide transporter
and this partially takes advantage of
the fact that there's a charge
difference between atp
and adp to actually couple
membrane potential to exchange of atp
adp
between the cytosol and the
mitochondrial
matrix now there's other issues we'll
talk about next time as well
and so remember some metabolism is
happening
in the cytosol so glycolysis
turning glucose
into pyruvate is occurring
in the cytosol we've already discussed
that means you got to get pyruvate in
the mitochondria for the pdh reaction
but this is also generating nadh in the
cytosol and if that nadh
needs to transfer its electrons to
oxygen we also have to get that nadh
into the mitochondrial matrix or more
correctly transfer those electrons into
the mitochondrial matrix
turns out cells maintain distinct
nadnadh pools and the mitochondria in
the cytosol
that's part of the conditions that make
different
reactions favorable in each compartment
and how cells do that transfer those
electrons into the mitochondria
ends up being another important thing
that has to be transport that's
driven across these membranes where one
can use delta psi delta ph
and we'll talk about that at the start
of the next lecture thanks